[Music]
hey you guys
time for another tomes of terror book
review
now the one we're talking about today is
called
the devil of nanking by mo
hader now this book was originally
published back in 2004
and i believe its original title was
tokyo
now mo hater i guess is a british author
so i'm assuming it was
first published in the uk under that
title
it seems like they changed the title to
the devil of nanking for america for the
american market
uh and i think they have that listed as
2010. so i guess it was like several
years afterward
now i guess mo hader i this is the first
book of hers that i've read but like i
said she's a british author
and she kind of made a big splash with
her first novel which came out in 2000 i
think which is called birdman
and subsequently has made quite a career
for herself doing mainly thrillers
she does something called the walking
man series some of her stuff
i think her novel the treatment was even
made into a movie in belgium
so you know quite successful in that
genre
now this is also sort of a i guess you
would call it a crime thriller but it
has kind of like a different
spin on it it's not like a real
traditional you know what this reminds
me a lot of it reminds me a lot if you
guys saw and we uh reviewed it on the
show a while back but the um ridley
scott movie black rain which i think
came out in 1989 that had
michael douglas in it this reminds me
very much of that
in the sense that it's sort of like a
crime drama there's yakuza stuff in it
and it's kind of like a cultural clash
type of thing
and it also have has a lot of um
historical detail in it that's
um actually really well researched and
like integrated into the story
so you're essentially following two
stories
in this novel the first
story said in the present day is about a
girl
or a young woman rather named gray now
that's
not her real name but you never find out
what her actual name is
that's the only name she's ever known by
and uh
she was named that i guess she was in a
mental hospital for a long time and her
uh some like a friend of hers at the
mental hospital named her that
because she kind of looked and acted
like an alien
like a grey so she just kind of adopted
that for herself
gray is a fascinating uh protagonist
she was apparently and that's one thing
if there's one thing i could knock this
book for
is like i was really intrigued by her
backstory
because they i mean mo hater gives you
like some
hints of what was going on back then and
uh you know but it's kind of like
unspooled really slowly but a lot of her
background is kind of a mystery
not so much what happened but why it
happened like why she's the way she is
but that said i mean she's still like a
really interesting character but i wish
that i had known like a little bit more
about her
so she's this young woman and i guess
she grew up in a really
weird household like her parents were
really
overly protective of her and they
wouldn't let her read certain books
obviously they wouldn't let her watch
tv or anything like that so she's very
very sheltered
and she has like this weird thing where
she doesn't really know anything about
anything like she doesn't know anything
about how the world works or
anything like that which is a source of
great uh
frustration for her uh however when she
was a kid
one book that was in her parents house
that i guess they
you know because she she makes a a big
deal about
um them being really careful about what
books they allowed in the house but
there was this one little book
that apparently slipped through their uh
net you know through the radar under the
radar
and it was a this little orange book and
it mentioned
um the massacre of nanking which if you
didn't know
it's like a a real historical thing it
actually was kind of
underground information for a long time
but i think most people know about it
now
but it was essentially the japanese
coming into china into nanking which was
then uh
you know the capital of that uh portion
there
and uh massacring some people think uh
350
000 people we're talking um you know
corpses damming up rivers so many bodies
that people mistook it for a mountain
from far away like just
these terrible terrible atrocities so
that
is kind of like the background of this
so she
is reading this book and she uh has
become
for whatever reason which like i said
they don't go
you kind of find out a little bit later
on why she's so fascinated
by the nanking massacre i but you know
it's so it's
she's like obsessing about it and she
finds
in this little book about the massacre
this little kind of offhand
comment that apparently
there was a film taken
uh you know back when it was going on
during in
1937 and it showed a particular
atrocity that she has a particular
interest in or a particular fascination
with let's say that so as she gets older
she kind of
grabs everything she can grab like she
becomes obsessed with
the nanking massacre and particularly
with finding this
mysterious film which nobody seems to
know like where it went or where to
happen it was almost kind of like
a rumor that was mentioned somewhere and
like nobody has been able to find it
since then
so she becomes obsessed with finding it
now at some point
before the events of the book
she does something that
ends up with her being in a mental
hospital you don't find out what it is
until pretty much the end
but she ends up uh in there for a while
and while she's in there
like i said she becomes uh you know more
and more obsessed with the nan king
massacre she just draws pictures of it
she has like all these notes and
everything
so she tries to go to university like to
study uh
you know war atrocities and things like
that but then she kind of drops out
and then she decides that she is going
to take what little money she has
after after she gets out of the hospital
and she is going to track down
the person that supposedly made and or
owns
this mysterious film if only so that she
can tell people
that she didn't just make it up because
i guess one of the things
is that whatever was portrayed on this
film
i think that people in general that know
about this massacre didn't think that
things like that happened and she
is convinced that this film exists of
this happening
and so she wants to kind of find it so
she can convince herself as well as
others that she's not crazy that she
didn't imagine
this mention of it that was in the book
so long ago so she ends up going
to japan um she speaks some japanese
but like i said she has pretty much zero
money she didn't really make much of a
plan like i said she's very
naive in a lot of ways and doesn't
really
know much about regular life um
or doing like practical things so
she didn't really you know she went to
japan with like most of
her last money that she had and she
didn't really have any plan
other than hey i'm gonna find this guy
that supposedly has this film
and then that's kind of as far as it
went
so she goes to this university
uh and she meets this guy who supposedly
has this film and his name
is uh xi changming and he was chinese he
was uh
well he is he's still chinese as far as
we know
and uh he was actually a witness to
uh the nan king massacre he lifted that
lived there back in 1937
and he is supposedly the one that has
the film um and or made the film
and he is now a visiting uh professor
of sociology i think it is at a
university in
tokyo so she goes to see him it doesn't
go as well as she
planned uh he basically denies that he
has the movie he just doesn't want to
talk about it
and so then she's kind of left at sixes
and sevens
and she's kind of out in the streets of
tokyo uh homeless like with no money or
anything like that
now fortuitously she's uh kind of
getting ready to sleep on a bench or
whatever and this
weird i think he's an american dude i
can't remember he's american or uh
british or something like that but he
kind of comes across her
in this little uh you know shrine or
wherever she's staying at
and he says well she's like you know i
don't have any money and stuff and he's
like well i can give you a place to stay
i live in this really
big house with these couple of other
roommates that work
at a hostess club here in tokyo and uh
we
and he's like and i work there too like
as a bartender or whatever it is that he
does and he's like so i could get you a
job there
you could make some money you know you
could rent out this room we have this
big house it's mostly
it's it's kind of like a um it was an
abandoned house essentially they're kind
of squatting in it like he's like well
the
landlord comes by sometimes but
sometimes he just forgets to
and the whole like bottom floor of it
was all flooded out it's all kind of
falling apart and [ __ ] but he's like you
know
better than sleeping on the street now
obviously um
this dude he seems nice at first but you
know that anybody that goes up to this
you know kind of young woman in the
street is kind of like hey i got a place
to stay and i'll get you a job and stuff
you know he's gonna kind of turn out to
be a creep which she sort of does uh
later on and in ways that you probably
didn't imagine
but she doesn't really have much of a
choice uh so she goes along with it
and over the course of the story she
actually she ends up getting a job at uh
this tokyo
nightclub like a hostess club and even
though she thought because she's very
very
socially awkward and she's very very
naive and
and ignorant of people's ways and stuff
so she didn't really think she'd be all
that good at being a hostess
but as it turns out she's kind of weird
but she's
better at it than she thought she would
be you know i mean uh she gets a lot of
schooling from these two
russian girls who also work at the
hostess club so they kind of help her
out like put makeup on her and [ __ ] like
that because she doesn't know anything
about that
so as the story goes on at the club
it turns out that this there's this old
guy that comes in there
um this old gangster and he has this
really scary
woman who's his nurse or whatever i
think his name is uh fuyuki and then you
turn
you find out later that he's in the
yakuza now
while all of this is going on this is
another book that kind of
um flips back and forth between present
day and past
because while gray's story is happening
in the present
you're also getting interstitials where
xi changming the man who um is at the
university but who
survived the night king massacre back in
the day back in 1937 where he
you're kind of getting his um diary from
that time of like what was happening
and um that is like i said as far as i
know it's fictionalized but
um mo hader did a really lot of
research into what exactly
would have happened during that and that
part is like really horrific because
it's like him his wife is very very
pregnant
and um you know you kind of get things
like everyone just
moving out of the town like the japanese
coming in and all the atrocities that
came in their wake which are really
really horrible and really like horribly
described so lots of like trigger
warnings for pretty much everything i
mean
you know animal cruelty baby killing
cannibalism pretty much anything you can
think of
you know rape so just know that going in
it's not
the descriptions of it or are horrific
but
i mean i've read worse but
the fact that this is researched and
you know that this stuff probably really
did happen
uh makes it a lot harder to read about
so just kind of know that going into it
you so you're kind of
so what's going on is that you get like
shi chong ming's
diary and he's kind of leading up to
you know what his life was like at first
and then like when the japanese came and
invaded nanking and like what happened
like everyone you know kind of tried to
run like some people got killed they
were all starving
and then what happened when they tried
to escape
and then kind of goes uh you know leads
up to
you know the thing that happened when he
made the famous film
at which point the two stories kind of
converge because what ends up happening
is that gray knows that he has this film
and she wants to see it really really
badly like i said she's completely
completely obsessed
with this film he does not want to show
it to her for
reasons which become clear later on at
first he denies that it even exists or
that he has it
um but you know as time goes on he does
have it and he was the one that made it
um so they kind of after a while they do
a lot of back and forth she keeps
bugging him he keeps trying to put her
off
but you know finally she's just like
look i'm not gonna leave you alone until
you
you know show me the movie so finally he
says okay well i'll make you a deal
he's like i will show you the movie if
you
you know because he knows at this point
that she works at the hostess club and
that uh fuyuki the
the yakuza boss guy goes there all the
time and that he
you know likes her particularly and uh
that she's been to his house
for like parties and stuff he's like
okay well
fuyuki has this thing
he's like i don't really believe it does
this but he believes it's something that
makes him live forever i don't think
it's like makes him live
like i don't think it makes him immortal
well he believes it makes him immortal
and he won't tell her what it is like
he's just kind of like
he's like well i'm not going to tell you
what it is because i don't want you he's
like well i don't really know
um so i want you to find out like you
know so if you're at his house you have
to like snoop around
even though obviously these are like
yakuza people and will just like
you know kill your face like immediately
uh so it's super super dangerous but she
wants to see this
movie so bad that she agrees to do it
without really knowing
exactly what she's getting into so
that's kind of the the bulk of the story
so the two
the you know the past the [ __ ] with the
diary and her present
are intertwined in ways that
are not immediately apparent so it's
almost kind of like
you know it's kind of leading up to this
big climax where
you find out how their fates are sort of
connected now as i said this is um
it has like horrific elements to it but
like i said it's mostly a crime thriller
and i think one of the best things about
it
is that i really really liked the
culture clash
element because she is british and she's
even though she knows japanese she knows
a lot about
japanese history but she's never lived
there before and she's kind of clueless
about
life in general not just in a culture
completely alien to her own
just even the stuff about her just like
navigating through everyday life and
just doing regular [ __ ]
is just kind of like really endearing i
guess i don't know if i'd call her a
likable character but she is for sure
a relatable character the other
characters it's this is kind of like one
of those books where all the characters
are sort of colorful or
not quirky because that seems like
rom-commy but
they're like weird in different ways
like like i said jason the one guy that
she meets
who initially offers her the place to
stay in the job
he turns out to be a total freakazoid
who is into her for
sort of nefarious reasons um then you
have
fuyuki and his nurse who
is essentially uh this big scary
woman who's just she's almost like the
way
the way that mo hader describes her
she's almost like an animalistic she's
like this really really big woman with
these really big hands and she has like
she always wears a wig and you can't
really see her face and there's
hints that she's done like like her uh
trademark
method of murder because of course she's
like a yakuza enforcer
and she's like one of the most feared
one and feared ones in tokyo
and uh the way that she kills people is
really um
really really disgusting so she's like
um
a really really scary character there's
also like really endearing characters
like the two russian girls
uh that are also that also live in the
house with uh
jason and gray and uh they're super cute
and uh the woman that runs the hostess
club
um what's what's she called madame
strawberry or whatever her name is
and she thinks that she's or she wants
to be marilyn monroe so she has had
uh plastic surgery to look more like
marilyn monroe she has
copies of all of marilyn monroe's like
iconic outfits and you know the
cigarette on the thing and
all this other kind of stuff and she's
like a really good uh character too
so there's all these kind of like
strange
characters in this really strange place
in this really strange situation with
this backdrop of
yakuza crimes and war atrocities and
stuff like that if that sounds like a
strange combination it sort of is but
i don't know something about it like
really really worked for me
also i will say too that the writing in
this is just so
i loved the descriptions of
tokyo i mean the descriptions
particularly of the house where they're
living which
like i said is sort of like
semi-abandoned and this just like wild
garden in the background and it's just
like the the descriptions of it are
really really beautiful and like really
really evocative
and as i said i really i really dug gray
as a main character
even though it's like i said i don't
think i'd call her a likable character
it's like she doesn't seem like someone
you'd want to hang out with particularly
but she was like a really fascinating
character and i kind of wish
you do get into her head a little bit
because you know the
the parts that are in the present day
are from you're in the first person
they're from her point of view
but i do kind of wish that that there
had been more about her past like why
were her parents
like that like what you know because
there's really no reason she just kind
of says
oh they're just like super
overprotective but the fact that
she doesn't even know like she doesn't
know how to do just like
completely mundane regular [ __ ] like she
doesn't know how to
drive she doesn't know how to put gas in
a car she doesn't know how to pay bills
she doesn't know how to do anything like
that
and it's just really interesting i would
have liked more about why her parents
were like that and why
yeah i don't know it was just like a
it's it's just a really weird thing but
she's like a really weird character but
i really really
liked that also not she didn't go too
much into why in particular
she was so obsessed with the nan king
massacre like why she initially got
obsessed with it you do find out later
why she was so obsessed with the film
um because of what the film shows and
she wanted to see that in particular
because like i said there was a
connection there like i won't spoil it
you know that's kind of explained but
there was a lot of stuff that was
left a little bit unexplained it's like
a lot of it's sort of implied but
you know you can kind of read into it
but anyway um yeah so if you like crime
thrillers like i said this reminded me a
lot if you like black rain
that um that ridley scott movie from
1989
uh this is it's not exactly the same
because that because that was kind of
more like a hard-boiled
police procedural type thing and this is
more like a
weird i don't know this is more like a
you know kind of war atrocities
meets strange
girl in a hostess club kind of and then
with yakuza stuff it's just it's a
really strange combo
but it really does work actually and
it's interesting because i was reading
some of the goodreads reviews and a lot
of people really dug her first uh couple
novels
which i think were also crime thrillers
but some people like a lot of people
really like this one but then some
people couldn't really
hang with it and i'm not really sure why
because i just thought this was really
really cool and it
it's something that i don't think i've
ever read another
crime thriller that was that was written
in this particular way or that was
in this particular setting and i think
that the
novelty of it was like really cool
because it's not really structured
exactly like a standard thriller and has
like a bunch of different
elements to it that you don't usually
see in
more standard kind of examples of the
genre so i really really like that so if
you're looking for a crime thriller that
has kind of something different
and has kind of like a historical touch
to it like i said
uh trigger warnings for pretty much
everything a lot of the [ __ ] that's
described in here is
pretty horrific and uh probably more
horrific because
a lot of that [ __ ] did happen uh in real
life and so that's pretty disturbing
but uh yeah so if you're looking for
something like that i would definitely
recommend this book it's really really
good
um i had a really good time reading it
as weird as that sounds as
because a lot of the [ __ ] that happens
in it is really horrifying
but yeah um as i said this is called in
the u.s at least it's called the devil
of
nanking if you're in other countries i
believe it's just called
tokyo and it came out in 2004 but yeah
that'll do it for
this tomes of terror and i will see you
guys on the next one
bye